alright there's this really inspiring
story here that we can share with you
it's about astronaut Christina cook and
her return to Earth this morning after
nearly a year in space a whole year in
outer space a Soyuz capsule carrying
cooked touchdown in Kazakhstan today
cook spent a record-breaking 328 days on
the International Space Station that is
the world's longest single space flight
by a woman while on orbit she was part
of the first all-female spacewalk with
fellow NASA astronaut Jessica Muir her
lengthy mission will give researchers
new data on how weightlessness in space
affects the female body was up there so
long she said she actually forgot she
was floating yeah 11 days she would have
had the all time like the human record
he's still smiling yeah real the way it
looked it was so crystal-clear on the
screen yeah she she was happy she was on
CTM last in december she said it's not
how many days are up but what you do
with each of those days all right Thank
You Vlad